california es golpeada de lleno por una
sequía histórica la escasez de agua
obligó a las autoridades a imponer
restricciones este año los jardines no
lucirán su habitual verde con la
limitación de irrigar en exteriores sólo
un día por semana en el sur del estado
es necesario reaccionar ahora para
realmente tener agua disponible para
nosotros en interiores para que bebamos
y para nuestra seguridad así que esto es
una crisis esto no tiene precedentes y
debemos hacerlo ahora ese es un
presidente aunque las restricciones se
aplicarán a partir del primero de junio
en decenas de ciudades de los condados
de los ángeles ventura y san bernardino
en los que habitan unas 6 millones de
personas
california el estado más poblado de
estados unidos con cerca de 40 millones
de habitantes posee varias fuentes de
agua provenientes de lagos y ríos
también en las montañas y esas reservas
se están secando
no hay nieve que se derrita y ese es el
cambio del clima lo sabemos según
expertos el cambio climático es un
factor fundamental en esta crisis
el cambio climático ha alterado
fundamentalmente el ciclo de agua de
nuestro estado intensificando el clima
extremo y provocando periodos más largos
y secos las autoridades se recomiendan
bajar el consumo no imprescindible en un
35% para que los suministros sigan
siendo viables
cuál es el peor de los resultados si la
gente ignora las medidas no quiero
llegar ahí pero podemos llegar a un día
en el que abras el grifo y no salga agua
en internet a paneles de la cámara del
30 al 70% del agua que se utiliza en los
hogares o negocios se emplea en
exteriores por lo que las medidas son
más estrictas para la jardinería y es
que ya son tres años consecutivos de una
sequía severa por lo que se plantea la
posibilidad de aplicar restricciones aún
más drásticas a partir de septiembre